[Music]
okay Tom and Jenny we're back at it
again and yeah we just got done seeing
overlord which was the world war two
movie about Operation Overlord which was
a movie about my unit actually it's
we're talking about the 506 then one
hundred and first Airborne Division you
know the they're all they all got spades
on their helmets and lead NCO inside
inside the bird was you know said
Currahee Devery buddy so that was my old
unit that was 506 and Overlord was about
putting much a pair of troopers behind
the defense's - right right before d-day
to kind of like soften the the German
response to d-day and in this one the
guys you know they get scattered just
like just like we actually did or my
unit actually did but this small team of
guys find they an experimental medical
facility that the Germans were doing to
make some super soldiers kind of
reminded me something out of this movie
that was an old movie called shockwaves
kind of like that in like they were
making this serum and [ __ ] happens
basically all right the movie to me I'm
gonna give you the good first not give
you the bad you know and then Jenny can
give her opinion the movie has a very
authentic look to the equipment it they
spent a lot of money to make this look
like a World War 2 movie the acting was
good
everybody did a pretty good job and
the big downfall from me and the movie
that kept throwing me out of it is that
at this time in actual history during
Operation Market Garden the 506 was a
segregated unit there were no black guys
in it all the black paratroopers were in
the 5o v it seemed to the 555 with a
triple nickel and I got guys in my unit
watching this video right now some of
them are black like well buddy Kennedy
weren't any black dudes you know and
that's kind of disrespectful it's kind
of throwing me out of it it's like
denying segregation I mean what are they
gonna deny next they're gonna deny the
Holocaust so I didn't really like that
aspect of it seems like they're just
trying to make a buck you know now you
could come back and say well this is an
alternate universe and that may have
been an angle but the thing is is that
they didn't really they didn't really
portray it as that you've got to choose
a lane and stick with it you don't I
mean so that part of it the tone wasn't
right if you ask me I think they really
should have done what another movie did
it's very similar in it I think superior
to this movie was Frankenstein's army
Frankenstein's army was clearly a horror
movie you know set in world war ii and
that it had a lot of sci-fi elements to
it it was more fun to watch it was
you're obviously watching something
that's kind of cartoonish and I think
that's the way they should have gone
this movie I think they tried to go with
realism and I think it backfired for me
I didn't think the horror was effective
in it I didn't think it was scary I
didn't think it was very innovative and
then the world war two sequences because
there were some firefights in him I
didn't think they were very inspiring I
didn't just oh firefighters happen okay
whatever
they weren't so
that think that what really pisses me
off about this movie is that it this
could have been something really great
but they just [ __ ] blew it if you ask
them the hinges just wasn't any fun to
watch you know I didn't I didn't think
it was I didn't think it was scary and I
didn't think it was exciting they should
have
I think Frankenstein's army was a
superior movie did this so I can't
really recommend it what do you think
Jamie I disagree I actually really
really likes this movie um I thought it
was really well paced I thought it was
like had some really creepy moments all
the acting was really good I liked a lot
of the gore you know it's very violent
and that kind of [ __ ] um you know the
realism aspect doesn't really bother
ma'am and you're talking about super
soldiers it's kind of supernatural
really so I'm not really concerned about
you know the people in it and what that
really doesn't occur to me so but
honestly like I really liked I really
liked it I really did I just I was
riveted through the whole thing I just
it was some really nice like creepy
shots in it like the cinematography was
really nice yeah you know it was well
fine it's a well made movie it is I
always enjoy seeing Nazis get [ __ ] up
so that's that was a plus but yeah it's
like really I you know I really really
enjoyed it and I'm surprised that you
did it yeah I didn't like but I really
really liked it a lot I did I would
recommend it even at the time would not
yeah I didn't think it was a very good
World War 2 movie I didn't think I
didn't think the World War 2 action or
the the firefights were were exciting at
all and I didn't think the horror was
that good at that the super soldier
aspect of it it just it wasn't it wasn't
scary to me
you know I thought it Frankenstein's
army freaking out you know they were so
inspected yeah that's more before yeah
so much more no no no no this was a
serious yeah yeah yeah I just there was
something about something about steam
it's really kind of two different John
yeah I think that they should have gone
the route of like it's funny because
when I saw the trailer
I think the trailer made it look more
like Frankenstein's army but I liked
that it was more serious because I was I
was thinking that it was going to be
more like that implied that's also
really good I just but I actually really
did like just the way it was I just kind
of thought it was boring
my mind was kept wandering during it was
like yeah alright yeah ok there's a
super-soldier syrup I was like alright
but that's not that impressive
now that then you're right there was a
couple couple of scenes in there that
was like oh wow this is gonna be alright
like when they found a head
yeah and I got spoiler for they found
this head in it that freaked me out I
was like wow you know this thing's gonna
be pretty intense probably but it never
never really delivered on that level and
then there was an another thing that I
think they got a lot right but they just
just missed it for me it just it missed
the mark I didn't I didn't have a strong
reaction to it I didn't really care and
just seemed kind of mediocre that's like
I said it was really well paced it was
there I don't think there was any boring
parts it just I hated it and the reason
why I hated is not because it did
anything wrong I hate it because it was
just so mediocre it was like to me it
was like a missed opportunity that it
really could have done something good
with it
with the right tweaks but just I just I
just thought it was kind of boring all
right okay
[Music]
okay Jenna and I are back at it again at
AMC
I'm here you want to hold this Jenna
here you want me to hold it yeah but you
figure out okay alright we just got done
seeing the girl in the spider's web what
do you think of I actually thought it
was fantastic I'm really I really liked
the original series like I read the
books and then I saw both the Swedish
and the American remakes when it came
out and I liked all of those this is
obviously you know the guy that wrote
the Millennium Trilogy passed away many
years ago so this is like a story with
all the same characters and with the
same you know feel to it but it was you
know written by someone else obviously
so they just kind of took it I actually
really like it had um sort of a James
Bond type feel as I was gonna say you
know but more grounded I guess you're
kind of a more realistic sort slightly
more realistic and not as though you
don't laugh you know not as glamorous
obviously because it's you know it's
said in Stockholm it's all very snowy
and all very square you know everything
there is square square building square
rooms yeah gray had a good winter theme
Jim Android and actually yeah that kind
of goes along with them with all the
other movies as well because a lot of
them kind of had that same just
everything was white and and everything
like that but it was actually this was a
really good story like I said it was
same same kind of thing as the other
ones except you know obviously if
someone's gonna kick lisbeth salander's
ass or is actually gonna be thing with
her because you know it's you know the
old one like she's like a super genius
computer hacker anything like that it's
gonna be someone who's related to her so
you have somebody who's on the same
level as her so you know the stakes are
much higher in at the end actually
reminded me a little bit of Skyfall
where he's like returning to your
childhood home yeah that type of thing
yeah so like I said it had a very James
Bond kind of feel but with a different
kind of spin on it
yeah yeah okay I liked it yeah I liked
it yeah
basically what you're dealing with is a
Swedish spy movie yeah even though even
though the the main character is a
hacker
she's very spy like and she's dealing
with dealing with you know CIA agents
and you know rogue criminal terrorist
type organizations good gunplay a lot of
times though they showed the gun so
quick that couldn't identify what make
and model certain things were me being a
gun freak on what was that she has a
pretty cool bike it uh it's a Ducati
Monster looked like one of the
air-cooled models which kind of reminds
me of my my fuel lightnings that I have
you know so she had pretty good take
head nabis on it she had some pretty
cool taste in motorcycles pretty good
gear the story I would say very much in
the vein of James Bond and you know like
mission impossible because there was
some group action where her and the
spies we're doing missions together even
though they kind of happen by accident
but that's just just the way it is when
you see it you know if you like if you
like the new Bond and you like Mission
Impossible this is right there with it
yeah if you like the other if you like
the hooks particularly because I love
the books I read all three of them in
like two days or something like that and
actually I really like the Swedish films
they made from it and the American
remake sort also reviewed and the
American remakes actually a Daniel Craig
in them so yeah I saw the connection
there when I saw the trailer to this
movie I didn't think I was gonna like it
but what you're seeing in the trailer is
like the first five minutes of the damn
movie there has nothing to do with the
rest of them it's like the first five
minutes and the last five minutes it's
it's good it can stand on its own it can
compete with with a Bond flick or
Mission Impossible flick without really
copying them it is its own yang but if
you liked those two series you will like
this yes I should say that even if you
haven't seen the other ones this one is
fairly easy to follow
it does have callbacks to the other ones
like McHale bloom
blumquist is in this also and so there's
some [ __ ] there with some repeating
characters Packer character who I think
it's his name is plague if I remember
the book correctly you don't need you
don't need to have seen it it's like you
know you'll pretty much catch on to
what's going on it's pretty well
explained it's pretty well laid out
I saw the Nami Rapace once yeah but it
was so long ago I don't remember
anything about them and then I remember
to be in like console oh this one was
not yet
I didn't like them the other ones I mean
the other one the first one you know the
girl with a dragon's head it was
actually more of a mystery yeah than a
spy this is a spy through it this is
definitely a spy through like
international terrorism type of thing
and I liked uh you know even the fact
that you know when you look at her I
mean we got to be honest folks she's 110
pound girl she's not gonna be beaten
[ __ ] ass you know I mean but she does
go hand to hand with some guys and how
she does it is kind of realistic you
know man she's mostly armed they didn't
make her super now she's not super
strong and she did get in a fight with a
guy who's mammoth must weighed twice
what she weighed and yeah he whipped her
ass that's right guys that weighed twice
I can pick you up it's kind of all over
there's not much you can do I think I
could just pick you up yeah yeah oh man
that's that's but yeah like I said I
mean you know obviously with the spy
forum was there was gonna be like a
little bit of suspension of disbelief
but I really didn't find that much at
all it's you know there was nothing in
there I was going no way I don't be able
to do that you know what I mean it's it
was pretty like fairly realistic I
thought yeah I liked it yeah I'd
actually want to see the second part
because I know that this is gonna be you
see yeah when are they gonna do another
trilogy now sure why wouldn't they I
think the movie will do well
it was yeah I put this right next to my
mission impossible in my James Bond DVDs
or blu-rays yeah that's how like this I
didn't like overlord didn't like
overlord I like this yeah but uh I
recommend it it's good
okay it's Tom and Jenny were back at it
again just got done seeing the Grinch
and you know it's based on How the
Grinch Stole Christmas yep it's a good
dr. Seuss movie look I grew up watching
her read the dr. Seuss books a little
kid and what do you think of this one
gentle I actually thought it was
adorable
they really expanded the story out I
mean obviously everyone's very familiar
with the original one they animated one
that had like Boris Karloff doing the
voice of the Grinch yeah but that you
know that one was only like twenty four
minutes long yeah
so a lot of stuff you know it's very
short but this one since its kind of
expanded out to movie length you know
they went into a lot of his planning and
like all the fries and [ __ ] that he
built you know what I mean to like steal
the who's Christmas and everything and
then they also made cindy-lou who kind
of like a larger character and how she
was gonna try and kidnap saying that
because she had asked him something and
all this other stuff so there was like
the - they kind of kept a cool you know
little parallels between the two
characters so I had a little bit like I
liked the relationship between the
Grinch and max they almost had kind of a
little wallace and gromit thing
where they had like yeah yeah so they
had to have a Wallace & Gromit thing
going where they had like all these
crazy gadgets like you know and Max
would like bring his coffee like up
these little you know every Goldberg
devices and stuff like that so they use
that in there but yeah and like I said
animation beautiful you know it's all
very Christmassy all the snow and all
the lights and everything like that I'll
pair the fur like what's really cool um
I didn't I didn't know like because when
I saw the trailers I was like I'm that
probably looks like it's gonna be cute
but I wasn't sure if I was on board with
Benedict Cumberbatch doing the voice for
the Grinch but actually I think it kind
of worked
yeah that was the only thing that was
one of the main issues I had when I
first started watching the movies like
man this voice does not match what I
remember as a kid now you told me that
was Boris Karloff and made a lot more
sense but as he gets a little more evil
in certain parts certain scenes he does
start to sound a little more like the
Grinch that I remembered but I'll tell
you one thing that this movie succeeds
on all fronts where Nutcracker failed
yeah I mean super this is everything
that Disney is not doing nowadays it's
it's a lot of fun good morality tales
they did kind of keep the of what a real
Christmas theme is about matter of fact
they sang some real Christmas carols in
the back yeah modern and traditional so
it wasn't kind of shine away totally
secularizing Christmas there's a couple
of things in there we go yeah they are
saying that the Christmas is a religious
thing you know which I like that the
music is good the way that the animation
is really good it's yeah it's astounding
it did capture this real weird surreal
quality of being cartoonish and real at
the same time I like some of the stuff
really looks like it's there like the
paint's chipping often little things on
the walls and these it was
really good details yeah I mean
obviously this is you know the same
students illumination studio same ones
that do yeah in all those and it's
hilarious it's very funny the the fiscal
comedy was very good so I really would
say that in the genre of a Christmas
movie from the family this one is up
there I know this is one that I would
definitely take this over the Nutcracker
Nutcracker was just super fun like all
the characters all the detail like
there's just such great little gags yeah
and it's just like soup the camera
angles just it's just everything about
it this is a this is a top-notch
Christmas movie yeah the holidays yeah
exactly look choke you up at the end and
everything I've always loved the bridge
you know the cartoon one back but I
think this one I didn't see the Jim
Carrey one because I couldn't deal with
it but like but this one is really a
worthy successor like yes and you know
it expands out the universe you get to
music done by Danny Elfman yeah I get to
meet a lot of the town's folk you know
knows and like there's a lot we have
character development and stuff like
that so and you get to kind of look a
little bit into the Grinch's past and
like yeah he's wide in like why do so
crabby and I have to save little baby
Grinch like when he's a little kid yeah
but I think we both agree that they
knocked it out of the park with this one
yeah really
if you want to see Christmas movie this
is one he's needed see ya
[Music]